[Music]
more than 400 million people passed
through EU ports each year current
legislation assures very high safety but
accidents still happen although very
infrequent over the years cruise ship
and ferry disasters have resulted in
hundreds of deaths for the Baltic Sea to
the Mediterranean and the North Sea in
some cases search and rescue efforts
have been hampered by inaccurate or
incomplete passenger lists but under new
EU rules passenger data would be sent
digitally to national authorities within
15 minutes of a ship's departure that
includes nationality mobile phone number
and emergency contact and any
information about special needs
technical standards have also been
updated for ship's construction fire
protection and stability mandatory
inspections must be done throughout the
year there are already robust rules in
place governing the construction
inspections and safety procedures for
passenger ships the scope of those
regulations will now be extended to new
kinds of ships they are also being
adapted to keep pace with evolution and
ship design and operation as well as the
sector's technology
[Music]